colombia entró en su sexta semana de
manifestaciones y la jornada comenzó de
forma no muy tranquila aquí en la
capital bogotá después de que un grupo
de indígenas misa que intentarán
derribar las trata del colonizador
cristóbal colón siendo y sonidos por el
small el escuadrón móvil antidisturbios
de las drogas es lagrimógenos y
aturdidoras dejando 10 indígenas heridos
según reporta las autoridades indígenas
también aquí en la capital de bogotá en
el parque nacional
el comité del paro ha organizado la gran
toma de la ciudad donde prevén marchar
hacia el hotel tequendama donde está
reunida la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos que se encuentra en
colombia para verificar los abusos de
los derechos cometidos durante el marco
en el marco de la protesta y del paro
nacional que lleva más de un mes y medio
por ello hoy la jornada se va a
trasladar allí y para llevarle a sus
reivindicaciones las reivindicaciones de
la calle y para demostrar que las
marchas son pacíficas pero también para
llevarle un mensaje a la comisión de que
quieran que estos abusos se verifiquen y
sean denunciados y el estado pueda tomar
acciones contundentes